on va passer à l'interview mensonges
mais j'aimerais Serge comtesse un petit
peu la lumière dans son image fixe ne
bougeait plus
[Applaudissements]
voilà
du mensonge comme d'habitude à la
télévision les interviews vous répondez
par des mensonges c'est tout à fait
toujours tout ce qui bouge
je pense à force de faire chier les
blancs
alors je suis je suis antisémite je
déteste les Juifs
[Applaudissements]
et vous comment vous trouvez
physiquement très beau
est-ce que vous avez donné pour le télé
il y a quelqu'un à chaque fois qu'il
fait comme si les gens pouvaient pas
réagir
[Applaudissements]
c'est vachement c'est un truc super
spontané quand même c'est génial on
continue du mensonge vous êtes à combien
de pétard par jour
le matin 10 le midi et 3 le soir
est-ce que vous connaissez
Hollywood night
[Musique]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu